bonjour à tous
il ya deux ans j'ai comment
un projet pour aider les professeurs des
écoles à devenir des super prof ça
commençait par créer un outil pour leur
permettre d'enseigner la lecture de
façon différenciée c'est à dire en
s'adaptant à chacun de leurs élèves
la première fois que j'ai parlé de ce
projet à un prof
il m'a dit ah ça a l'air génial mais est
ce que ça marche
alors j'avais très envie de lui dire oui
oui bien sûr que ça marche c'est moi
qu'il fait mais à la place je lui ai
demandé qu'est ce que ça veut dire au
juste
ça marche depuis deux ans c'est une
question qu'on nous pose souvent
est ce que ça marche et à chaque fois
quand on demande ce que ça veut dire
les réponses tourne autour de la vitesse
d'apprentissage des élèves qui doit
augmenter quand les étudiants de
l'université technologique de compiègne
m'ont proposé de venir m'exprimer ici
sur le thème de la vitesse ils m'ont
naturellement proposé de parler de la
vitesse d'apprentissage des élèves
ça me posait quelques problèmes alors
pour être clair je suis convaincu que la
question est ce que ça marche
elle est fondamentale si on ne se pose
pas ce genre de questions on avance à
l'aveuglé par contre je pense que la
grille de lecture de la vitesse quand on
se demande est ce que ça marche pour un
outil pédagogique
ce n'est ni la seule ni la meilleure
aujourd'hui pour commencer je voudrais
vous expliquer pourquoi on associe ces
questions de temporalité à l'éducation
assez naturellement quand on passe un
examen un concours une épreuve que ce
soit en une heure en deux heures ou en 4
heures il faut répondre en temps limité
l'école commence à 8h30 on a quinze
minutes de récréation une heure et demie
pour manger 15 minutes l'après-midi ont
fini à 17 heures dans la semaine on
travaille quatre ou cinq jours c'est
d'ailleurs une grande question
aujourd'hui est ce qu'il faut travailler
quatre ou cinq jours on commence en
septembre
on a une semaine de vacances à la
toussaint deux semaines à noël deux
semaines en février de semaine à pâques
et presque deux mois de grandes vacances
finalement l'école est obligatoire de 6
à 16 ans il y a trois années d'école
maternelle cinq années d'école
élémentaire
quatre années de collège toujours ce
rapport à la temporalité aux rites au
rythme au rythme mais finalement est-ce
que le rythme a toujours été liée aux
scolaires
on se pose la question de la
transmission du savoir au moins depuis
l'antiquité
par contre l'école telle qu'on la
connaît aujourd'hui
elle date à peu près des années 1880
avec les lois ferry qui la rendent
gratuite laïque et obligatoire pour tous
une véritable révolution une révolution
qui en suit une autre la révolution
industrielle
et quand on y regarde de près les cols
elle a été créée dans un contexte
industriel pour des besoins industriels
et dans un contexte industriel quand on
se demande est-ce que cet outil il est
performant
on va se dire est ce que ça marche sinon
on va regarder si l'ouvrier quand on va
lui donner cet outil il va pouvoir
travailler plus vite et mieux
le parallèle avec le système éducatif
c'est que l'enfant qui apprend son
travail c'est d'acquérir des compétences
des connaissances est donc un bon outil
pour lui c'est quelque chose qui va lui
permettre de le faire plus vite et mieux
et finalement c'est un système qui a
bien fonctionné pendant presque 150 ans
pourquoi ce serait différent aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ce qui est différent c'est
que on ne réduit plus l'apprentissage à
l'enfance on considère que quelqu'un qui
commence à travailler aujourd'hui ne
fera plus le même métier dans 30 ans il
va devoir se former pourquoi ce serait
différent aujourd'hui
parce qu'aujourd'hui si je vous demande
de savoir comment présenter une
conférence ted
si je vous demande de quand datent les
doigts ferry ou alors ce que vous savez
sur l'intelligence artificielle
votre premier réflexe courant vous
renseigner est ce que c'est vraiment
d'aller à l'école aujourd'hui vous allez
regarder sur internet et c'est très bien
ainsi
le rapport à la connaissance s'est
modifié
pourquoi c'est différent c'est différent
parce qu'aujourd'hui on entre dans une
conception du monde où ce qui peut être
automatisée doit être automatisées et
c'est bien personne n'est
fondamentalement heureux de faire la
même tâche répétitive 35 heures par
semaine pendant 40 ans avec cinq
semaines de congés payés
on a l'impression que cette conception
elle existait déjà à l'époque
industrielle automatisés mais c'est
différent
à l'époque industrielle automatisés
c'était de gagner en productivité
c'était éventuellement prendre un
ouvrier et le mettre sur une chaîne de
montage pour que ce soit plus efficace
aujourd'hui ce qu'on veut automatiser
c'est ce qu'on n'a pas envie de faire
mais ce qu'on a envie de faire
on peut le faire ça fait des années que
je joue aux échecs les ordinateurs
savent le faire mieux que nous pour
autant si vous avez envie de jouer aux
échecs
rien ne vous empêche de le faire et vous
serez ravis de le faire alors finalement
est ce que ça marche bien ça dépend déjà
de quoi on parle de quelles compétences
on parle dans les années 2000 il ya un
groupe de chercheurs américains qui
s'est posé cette question quelles sont
les principales compétences à acquérir
pour les enfants aujourd'hui pour le 21e
siècle esprit critique communication
collaboration créativité esprit critique
communication collaboration créativité
ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'aucune
de ces compétences ne s'analyse
facilement avec une grille de lecture
liés à la vitesse esprit critique
communication collaboration créativité
est-ce que c'est pertinent de demander
si quelqu'un a un esprit rapidement
critique
est-ce que c'est pertinent de savoir si
quelqu'un collaborent vite ce n'est pas
forcément une qualité
par contre se demander si deux personnes
ont ensemble une communication profonde
ça c'est intéressant de se demander si
quelqu'un à une créativité qui est
source d'idées originales qui ont de la
valeur
ça semble plus pertinent déjà alors est
ce que ça marche pour analyse cette
question on a notre disposition trois
grandes théories pédagogiques
la première théories pédagogiques elle
s'intéresse à savoir si suit un
apprentissage un apprenant est capable
de donner une réponse juste à une
question posée si je demande à un enfant
qui vient d'apprendre ces tables de
multiplication combien font trois fois 5
et qui ne me répondent qu'à 15
c'est très bien la deuxième grande
théories pédagogiques
elle s'intéresse à savoir si à partir de
ses connaissances un apprenant est
capable de construire son savoir si on
dit un enfant que trois fois 5 ça fait
15 et que trop facile ça fait dix-huit
et s'il est capable tout seul donc
conclure que trois fois 11
ça fait 33 c'est super et c'est super
même si la faux c'est à dire s'il
considère que trois fois sans que ça
fait 15 et que trois fois ci ça fait 16
ce qui est faux eq alors trois ans a
fait 31 ce qui est faux aussi on est
content quand même parce qu'il a compris
le principe
il a compris que trois fois en onze
c'est la même chose que 3,5 pouces trois
fois 6 la troisième grande théories
pédagogiques
elle s'intéresse à la métacognition et
au groupe
elle s'intéressait à mettre ensemble ces
deux élèves celui qui connaît ses tables
de multiplication et qui n'a pas compris
le principe est celui qui ne connaît pas
ses tables et qui a compris le principe
et va voir si ensemble ils peuvent
répondre à cette question 3 x 11 en
ayant tous les deux la bonne réponse est
compris le principe aujourd'hui notre
système éducatif
ils s'intéressent beaucoup à sept
premières théories pédagogiques qu'on
appelle le behaviorisme on va enseigner
ensuite on va poser des questions on va
voir si les réponses données sont bonnes
un outil pédagogique et pertinents s'il
augmente le taux de bonnes réponses
données par les élèves dans les études
secondaires et dans les études
supérieures
on s'intéresse un peu à cette deuxième
théories pédagogiques on appelle le
constructivisme
on dit souvent mathématiques par exemple
que ce qui compte ce n'est pas tellement
de donner le bon résultat c'est surtout
d'avoir compris le principe
malheureusement à l'école on s'intéresse
peu aux socio constructivisme cette
troisième grandes théories pédagogiques
qui pourtant serait essentiel pour
analyser les grandes compétences dont je
vous parlais plus tôt
ces trois théories pédagogiques elles ne
sont pas du tout opposé elles sont
parties donc tous les trois elles sont
juste un angle de regard un an de
visions différents sur l'apprentissage
c'est intéressant de s'appuyer sur les 3
pourquoi est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui un
décalage entre ce que les chercheurs
considèrent être des bonne direction est
ce qu'on observe à l'école je vais vous
surprendre
pour une fois ce n'est pas la faute des
hommes politiques en effet l'éducation
nationale dans ces textes est très en
avance sur la pratique est généralement
en phase avec les grandes théories du
moment typiquement aujourd'hui on parle
beaucoup de resituer l'apprenant au
coeur du système éducatif de faire en
sorte que ce soit l'école qui s'adapte à
l'élève et pas l inverse
mais quand on regarde c'est dans les
textes depuis plus de 30 ans avec les
lois jospin sur l'éducation quand il
était ministre de l'éducation nationale
dans les derniers programmes scolaires
on voit l'apparition en classe de
maternelle de la notion d'algorithmes et
ce qui est très moderne qu'il ya un
décalage entre la théorie et la pratique
c'est normal ça a toujours été le cas le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui le
changement de paradigme qui a lieu est
très rapide et les réformes
structurelles que l'on doit mettre en
place
elles sont lentes elles sont très
pertinentes il faut repenser la
formation des maîtres
il faut repenser notre rapport à
l'évaluation c'est tout à fait pertinent
mais ça prend du temps dans la société
que j'ai co créé la l'îlot al ahly là on
s'intéresse à ce changement de paradigme
d'un point de vue technologique en
créant des outils technologiques
le bon point c'est que ça permet d'être
beaucoup plus rapide dans ces
changements mais on se confronte à deux
barrières psychologiques
la première barrière psychologique
elle est liée à l'inconnu d'une manière
générale il ya très peu de gens qui
comprennent ce que c'est les nouvelles
technologies et comme on parle d'enfants
une population fragile on trouve que ça
ne fait pas bon ménage de mettre quelque
chose d'inconnu avec des enfants une
population fragile
du coup une grande partie de notre
travail consiste à expliquer ce que
c'est que les nouvelles technologies
comment ça marche comment ça doit être
utilisé quel est l'objectif pour enlever
cette première barrière psychologique
la deuxième barrière psychologique
elle est liée à la peur du changement on
entend beaucoup que de nombreux métiers
mêmes intellectuels vont disparaître il
ya beaucoup de professeurs des écoles
qui viennent nous voir et qu'ils nous
posent des questions sur ce sujet je
vais vous dire quelque chose qui n'est
pas facile à dire et qui n'est pas
facile à entendre pour eux oui dans
quinze ans le métier de professeur des
écoles n'aura rien à voir avec celui
d'aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'il sera c'est
très dur de répondre à cette question
est en fait les meilleures personnes
pour répondre à cette question ce sont
les professeurs des écoles
d'une manière ou d'une autre nous tous
nous allons nous transformer en manager
d'intelligence artificielle
ce sera à nous de choisir quelle tâche
on a envie de déléguer à des
intelligences artificielles et quelle
tâche on a envie de garder à notre
niveau
alors est ce que ça marche fait la
réponse à cette question elle est très
simple oui ça marche
de toute façon il ya un système de
proches de la sélection naturelle qui
fait que l outil pédagogique qui ne
marche pas il n'est pas utilisé
finalement les outils pédagogiques qui
seront utilisés oui il marche
la vraie question qu'il faut se poser
c'est qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
marche
je ne dis pas que c'est une mauvaise
chose que de s'intéresser à la vitesse
d'apprentissage une grille de lecture
intéressante
je pense qu'il y en a d'autres et un
d'autres qui sont meilleurs se demander
si on peut diminuer l'échec scolaire
si on peut réduire les inégalités
sociales si on peut faire en sorte que
les enfants qui vont à l'école soit
heureux fier d'eux et qu'ils soient bien
préparés pour leur futur ce sont
d'autres grille de lecture qui sont
vraiment pertinente mais pour passer sur
ses grilles de lecture il faut que nous
tous dans cette salle nous changions
notre rapport éducation je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]